hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the following
I can barely hear some music in there
but my volume is cranked up so I'm not
gonna do it any louder just in case
there's jump-scare and it tries to kill
me okay so this game has been in my play
box for a while I've got a whole backlog
of stuff that I've been meaning to get
through so I'm still trying to plow
through these indie horror games so here
we go we are playing in the Unity engine
which I that sounds familiar
they still haven't fixed the mouse
problem the mouse can go out of the game
but that definitely sounds familiar
what's that from
from wanted to just the killer games
maybe I'm not sure but either way they
got a nice environment here I'm not sure
what that is what is that what is that
whoo hell are you I really like the
style or dial well what is that did you
get knocked over sir madam are you okay
do you need assistance do you require
assistance oh you're a chair haha okay
never mind then uh okay did was that
something is that something that's um is
it is that some is there some there ah
some onion or some you can't fool me I
knew you were some ah well wrong with
you
Jesus what's wrong with you you got
something on your face and chest and
you're weird what the hell are you what
the hell are you are you another chair
hello ah screw you
oh no I'm trapped ah I'll charge you
then you'll be the butt of my joke where
are you oh there you are
you're slow angel you're never gonna
catch me I'm the gingerbread markiplier
I'm the markiplier more bread man them
is that the whole assortment a haunted
choir in these halls ah what hello well
I can't Oh what the hell what the hell
just happened there did I get ported oh
this isn't a good thing it's not a good
thing those are so freaky
noises and what's with the rock okay I
am trapped and el bondo I am I'm going
to die oh are we in my ear holes
man the whoever made this game did a
good job of assembling all of the horror
noises in the world and putting him in
one place hang and I get to round my
volume for this cuz he's gonna eat me
he's gonna Gible on my niblets hello
let's get a look at you oh stop it oh
stop it you stupid doll what are you
doing uh uh okay I'm dead what the hell
ah
he's following I guess is the point of
the game don't do much hello mr. chair
well that's new the light went out well
good thing I got this super bright
flashlight alright so the noise that I'm
hearing is the origin of mr. saggy tits
I don't know
he's got boobs on him so I really don't
know what else to call him I don't even
know if he's a he he might be a she I
don't know haha you know why he's a
weird big doll with boobs and I don't
like him her him I don't know
and there's nothing here um is there
actually an objective that I need to be
looking for because I seem to be dropped
into an area with nothing hello
are you gonna fall over well the chairs
aren't jumping out of me this time
but I hear you I hear you if I make
scary noises - will you run away from me
probably not hello someone knocked this
chair over hi ha ha hi where'd you come
from
go away please I need to find the exit
which is over here or it's not I have no
idea I have no idea where the exit is
cuz I'm a
a scared little baby you know I went
down there before I won't be fooled
again
oh no wait I've been here before ah this
is the place this is a place I can't be
here though cuz this is this is dead-end
land maybe I don't know I don't know I
don't even know I'm here why am I here
no idea dead end dead end dead end was
that a dead end
is there something there right there no
up all dead ends I am doomed I am Lee
boned this guy is going to murder me if
he really murders me I don't even know
if that's what he does he might just
kind of look at you funny until your
head explodes
I guess it's murdering but at the same
time I don't know what his point ah damn
it another dead end he's gonna try me
again well anyway as far as the
environment goes is actually really rude
another light went out it's actually
really cool I like it because it's um
it's very stylized I mean obviously it's
not very graphically intense but
stylization is important in a game even
a horror game you know some people say
like you know take minecraft for example
its graphics her little subpar hey
weirdo its graphics are a little subpar
but at the same time that's its style it
is stylized to be blocks it couldn't
exist any other way than it is because
the whole mechanic of the game is based
on blocks ergo the world makes sense in
that style and it would look weird
if it was say photorealistic so I like
the styling that's what I'm trying to
say I went a long way to say that
hello light are you gonna break no I
don't even see a light bulb so let's
carry on I'm probably gonna try myself
in a dead end again again I'm boned cuz
he hi I'm gonna scoop
okay all right I don't know what the
point is um it's pretty cool otherwise I
mean um it's kind of weird I wish I wish
maybe um it was more feeling like
because it's kind of a cool concept
running away from a monster but I don't
know where I'm going and I mean there's
a difference between being lost and not
knowing where you're going because being
lost while something chasing you is
pretty terrifying but it didn't feel
like it was all that threatening to me
so it could be a little better but all
in all it's pretty good so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video
buzz
Oh